things stand there is still not  sufficient support in the house to bring  back the deal for a third meaningful  vote oh that many members across this  house are frustrated too and we all have  difficult jobs to do people on all sides  of the debate hold passionate views and  I respect those differences we are now  at the moment of decision and in doing  so we must confront the reality of the  hard choices before us unless this house  agrees to it No Deal will not happen no  bricks it must not happen and a slow  brexit which extends article 50 beyond  the 22nd of May forces the British  people to take part in European  elections and gives up control of any of  our borders laws money or trade is not a  brexit that will bring the British  people together